Пекарня в центрі Берліна.
Робота тут кипить з ночі.
Адже вже з 6 години ранку перед цим традиційним німецьким закладом
збирається черга за смаколиками та гарячою кавою.
Саме тут знайшли роботу пара українців, які мусили залишити рідну Одесу
одразу після повномасштабного вторгнення Росії.
Тетяна та Ігор, як і більшість українців, спробували звернутися за соціальною допомогою від німецької держави,
та зізнаються: майже одразу зрозуміли, що хочуть вставати на ноги самі та не отримувати соцдопомогу.
Вирішили: шукатимуть роботу та платитимуть податки у ФРН.
Я архітекторка за освітою, але на пенсії.
Ми приїхали, зіткнулися з соціальними службами.
Це важко давалося - сидіти в черзі, без мови, тоді ще не так налагоджено було систему.
Не так легко давалося. Треба було стояти в черзі, чекати, коли все вирішиться, а потім колись отримати гроші.
Ми вирішили, що ми підемо працювати.
Саме в цей час пекарня "Зіберт" з більш ніж 120-річною історією шукала працівників.
Ми шукали людей. Ігор відгукнувся. У нас було таке гарне відчуття, і ми сказали, давайте просто подивимось.
Їм все вдалося дуже добре з самого початку. Я насправді був задоволений ними.
Наразі Тетяна вже закінчила інтеграційний курс.
До вимушеного переїзду пара не знала німецьку мову.
Досвіду у випіканні смаколиків вони також не мали.
Обидва українці працювали раніше архітекторами.
Утім, це не завадило їм швидко опанувати нову професію навіть без знання мови.
Без лінійки ніяк.
Вони дивляться, вони працюють, знають, що ми робимо.
Ми показуємо. У Ігоря іноді є телефон (з перекладачем).
Тетяна вже навчилася непогано. Іноді вона розмовляє англійською, але також німецькою,
тому що хоче вивчити німецьку теж. Насправді все йде чудово.
Робота складна, але Ігор та Тетяна працюють із задоволенням.
Готово! Das ist fertig!
Ми ніколи не думали, що потрапимо у таку сімейну обстановку, коли ми, як удома.
Це просто не передати.
Кажуть, що робота з тістом і в колективі дозволяє відволіктися від новин з рідної Одеси.
Виїхали (з Одеси) ми через те, що заробітки зникли.
Треба було щось їсти та якось жити.
Оскільки ми не сидимо на дивані та не скаржимося, одразу влаштувалися на роботу.
Складно - нескладно, якщо руки на місці, то, звичайно, навчитися можна всьому.
Головне - витримка, бажання. За хорошу працю добре платять.
Це я зараз роблю die Schnecke. По-нашому - це равлики.
Роблю масу сама, яблука готую натуральні, отримую тісто, яке теж готується натурально.
Щодня у мене таких три-чотири пироги виходить.
Працювати старанно для Ігоря та Тетяни вкрай важливо,
адже вони не хочуть, аби про українців думали погано.
Знаєте, як ще - нас брали як українців.
І весь час у голові: "Ти всю націю представляєш".
Як думатимуть про те, які українці? Ми працюємо, як совість дозволяє.
Так само як Тетяна та Ігор, деякі українці, які опинилися в Німеччині після вторгнення Росії, також змогли знайти роботу.
Протягом 2022 року в Німеччині на 65 тисяч збільшилася кількість українців, які сплачують соціальні внески із зарплати.
У Федеральному агентстві зайнятості очікують на зростання цієї кількості.
Крім того, ще 21 тисяча українців мають так звану minijob,
тобто роботу у Німеччині з оплатою не більше 520 євро на місяць,
з яких зазвичай не сплачуються соціальні відрахування.
Нині інтеграційні та мовні курси в Німеччині відвідуються краще, ніж будь-коли раніше.
Саме завдяки такій підготовці, яку надає ФРН, змогла знайти роботу і Галина Корнієнко.
Разом з дружиною, двома котами та двома собаками вона змушена була виїхати з Гостомеля в перші дні вторгнення.
В Україні жінка працювала в громадських організаціях з фокусом на допомогу жінкам з вразливих груп.
Роботу жінці вдалося знайти за фахом -
зараз в Берліні Галина консультує українських жінок щодо жіночого здоров'я в німецькій громадській організації.
Коли самоорганізувалися, ми почали зав'язувати зв'язки з різними ЛГБТ організаціями,
жіночими організаціями, феміністичними організаціями.
Так ми познайомилися з Feministen Frauen Gesundheitszentrum.
Вони залучили грантові гроші на підтримку українських жінок,
на консультування стосовно жіночого здоров'я - для українських жінок.
В них з'явилося дві вакансії.
Це було їхнє свідоме рішення, що ці дві вакансії повинні зайняти українки.
Галина працює вже майже місяць.
І хоча роботу вдалося знайти через власні соціальні зв'язки,
навички працевлаштування і подачі резюме в Німеччині вона отримала під час підготовчих курсів.
Я на обліку в джобцентрі. Завдяки джобцентру я брала джобкоучінг.
Тобто консультування як саме в Німеччині влаштована система працевлаштування,
яким чином тут подають резюме, як його правильно складати, як складати мотиваційний лист.
Пройшла цей коучінг і так сталося, збіглося, якраз закінчився коучінг.
В мене були вже всі документи готові.
І тут в організації, яку я знала, з'явилася ця вакансія.
Галина вивчила німецьку до рівня B2.
Українка порівнює свій попередній досвід роботи з тим, що мала вдома і каже:
звикла присвячувати роботі більше часу.
Це вперше в моєму житті, коли я працюю на пів ставки.
В Україні зазвичай в мене було, коли я виїжджала, шість проєктів.
Там не регулювався робочий день. Я сама його собі регулювала.
Тут для мене дуже дивно - роботу лишаємо на роботі.
Коли я намагаюся підгребти документи, вдома попрацювати,
директорка каже: "Ні, вдома треба відпочивати, роботу лишаємо на роботі".
Українці шукають роботу в Німеччині на тлі складної ситуації на робочому ринку в країні.
У ФРН нестача кваліфікованих кадрів сягнула рекордного рівня,
попри нинішні порівняно низькі темпи розвитку економіки.
За даними Інституту німецької економіки, торік у Німеччині через відсутність відповідних кандидатів серед безробітних
вакантними залишалися понад 630 тисяч робочих місць.
Це пікове значення за весь час спостережень від 2010 року.
Через те, що покоління бебі-бумерів виходить на пенсію,
наш ринок праці просто сильно скоротиться, і тоді нам потрібна імміграція.
Щорічно Німеччина потребує близько 400 тисяч іммігрантів.
І ми маємо подбати про те, щоб зробити Німеччину більш привабливою.
У Німеччині активно розробляють так звану картку можливостей, яку зможуть отримувати іноземні працівники.
Новий документ має спростити вимоги до іноземців,
але є проблеми, які необхідно вирішити, якщо Німеччина хоче залучити іноземних працівників
і створити такі умови, щоб вони залишились і працювали в країні.
Нещодавно Німеччину назвали найгіршою країною у світі для емігрантів,
коли мова йде про такі важливі речі, як пошук житла, вивчення мови та цифрові послуги.
Чи можуть українці, які вже тут, розв'язати проблему з нестачею фахівців у Німеччині?
Ні. Це досить ілюзорно. Німеччині потрібні майже два мільйони працівників.
І якщо ми просто порахуємо. Це досить простий аналіз.
До Німеччини приїхало близько мільйона людей.
З них близько 40 відсотків - діти. Це означає, що мова йде про близько 600 тисяч.
Тут є момент - не всі хочуть залишатися тут, у Німеччині.
Наші результати показують, що лишатися хоче лише кожен третій,
тобто з 600 тисяч лише 200 тисяч могли б довгостроково інтегруватися на ринку праці.
Тож якщо порівняти 200 тисяч і 2 мільйони попиту,
то ми побачимо, що українці не можуть стати розв'язанням проблеми нестачі рук.
Навіть ті українці, які хотіли б працевлаштуватися і лишитися в Німеччині
стикаються з проблемами у питаннях мови та визнання кваліфікації.
Існує кілька перешкод для інтеграції українських біженців на ринок праці.
Передумови дуже хороші: є ступені та необхідні кваліфікації.
Людям ще треба вивчити мову.
Існують проблеми з визнанням (дипломів) і відсутністю догляду за дітьми, особливо для жінок.
Здолати ці перешкоди поки вдалося не всім.
Дослідження показують, що однією з причин сповільненого пошуку роботи є невизначеність,
яку несе з собою війна, адже багато хто планує повернутися додому після закінчення бойових дій.
Поки цього не сталося сидіти на місці Тетяна з Ігорем не планують
і кажуть, що час у Німеччині можна використати з користю.
От і робочий день закінчився.
Іноді я дуже радісно посміхаюся, що деякі люди лише в цей час прокидаються.
А я, вийшовши на вулицю, від цього відчуваю такий приплив сил, що зробила справу вже.
Ось стоїть черга, і люди їдять те, що я робила.
Коли дуже важко, я говорю чоловікові: "Я більше не можу, я їду до Одеси. Додому, я втомилася".
Він каже: "Почекаймо до кінця вихідних, і ти мені скажеш".
Зазвичай вистачає кінця вихідних, щоб знову йти (працювати)...
Але те, що важко, я не приховую. Важко всім. Працювати важко завжди.
Утім, робота хоч і виснажлива надихає пару продовжувати.
Ми цілий рік жодного дня не пропустили.
Удосконалюємося. Дуже багато чого навчилися і Ігор, і я.
Мені дуже подобається, коли Ігор каже: "Я себе таким кволим старим відчував, я не міг підняти нагору підноса.
Зараз я лівою однією закидаю".
Тобто ця дисципліна, активність надали нам і витривалості, і фізичного розвитку.
Повернемося ми - нові, оновлені, різні…
Ми ж скоріше піднімемо те, що зруйновано.